We all love spice in our meals
But do you know that 129 teaspoons of hot pepper may kill you
The concern is that even a teaspoon of nutmeg ..
It can cause convulsions, palpitations or nausea or death!
Sugar, of course, is linked to many diseases.
For a person weighing 68.18 kilo ..
10 cups and a half of sugar at the same time deadly.
These huge amounts of sugar will trap you with dangerous tooth decay.
But do not eat toothpaste.
Fluoride is very safe in small quantities and helps fight decay
But the consumption of about 24 tubes contains 170 mm
Or 0.17 liters of fluoride will be fatal.
If you are trying to avoid wrinkles,
You should know that 68 ng of Botox is deadly.
Botox is an abbreviation for toxic potassium.
Of course, injections use tiny proportions of that amount,
Which prevent the burning of nerves and necessary for muscle paralysis.
And always advise you to eat fruits and vegetables,
However, excessive intake of orange presents you with an overdose of vitamin C.
But access to overdose
Requires 11 thousand orange.
In contrast, 809 of dietary supplements give the same result.
If the healthy food will make you alienate him and away do not multiply it.
Although our bodies are treated with amazing speed,
But it is the opposite with the acceleration completely.
Earth revolves around the sun at 1600 kilometers per hour.
It does not affect you.
But if the earth begins to accelerate at high speed we will feel a tremor.
At 14 g of lateral acceleration.
Your body members will begin to fade one by one.
Quick running activates you.
But if the internal temperature reaches 40 degrees Celsius
Will be hit by a sunburst leading to death.
The sweating keeps the body temperature.
But the heat is extreme
Causes dry kidneys and brain.
As a result,
They will release harmful bacteria into the bloodstream.
And of course if your body's internal temperature drops to more than 21 degrees Celsius
Your body will enter a deadly phase due to low temperature
Causing veins tightness and low blood flow.
All you have to do is focus on heating your internal organs until you return to normal.
If you try to see these internal organs,
Avoid exposure to 7143 internal x-rays.
It is enough cumulative amount of radiation to kill you.
This ionizing radiation has enough energy
To remove the electrons from the atom.
5 impurities of radiation sufficient to kill 50% of the population
Such as the nuclear explosion!
If you are hiding from a nuclear explosion,
Be careful not to eat too many green potatoes in your graves.
The green on the crust is actually chlorophyll
It is non-toxic
But indicates the existence of the poison of Sulanin,
It is a defensive way to get rid of pests.
You may get sick because of green potatoes,
But eating 25 medium-sized tablets,
Your life will be at stake!
It is necessary for our survival to survive in small doses,
It may be fatal at times. Like potassium!
Potassium ions are essential for nervous pulse and muscle contractions,
In contrast, potassium chloride is used in lethal injection.
You need to eat 480 bananas to reach this lethal amount,
But your stomach will explode before you reach this amount!
Remember: The dose is poison!
If you want more examples of exotic things that can kill you,
See the first part of this section.
You can also watch our latest clip "When Scientists Go to Music Festivals!"
And stats to convince your friends of your favorite song.
Translation: team translate @autrjim